[Music]
welcome before we begin do know that a
lot of the information within this video
comes from the three fingers or agents
of the three fingers which means
they can all easily be lies as the three
fingers themselves is a force of chaos
and their agents are not much better
so take the information i gathered in
this video with a grain of salt
because that's just how obscure the
flames are
so i want to tackle the flames of the
game
namely the frenzied flame the god
slaying black flame and the flame of
ruin or the giant's flame
and maybe to an extent the taker's flame
but this one is more of an extra because
we only get it from reichardt
but after going through the lore of
these flames it was pretty convoluted to
talk about all of them in one video so
i'm splitting it up so the videos can be
more hyper focused on each of the flames
with this first video being about the
frenzied flame so make sure to subscribe
if you want to see more about the flames
now the reason i wanted to start with
the frenzied flame is because unlike the
gods laying black flame
or the flame of ruin the frenzied flame
is part of the order
it is technically speaking coming from
the same place as the greater will
albeit it is said that it was created as
a mistake
but i think i'm getting ahead of myself
first let's answer the question
what is the frenzied flame
[Music]
the simple answer is that it is chaos
incarnate it is the opposite of the
golden order where the two fingers are
the agents of order the three fingers
are the agents of chaos
it is difficult to say for sure if the
words of the three fingers can be
trusted seeing as they are chaos itself
but at the end of hieta's quest line she
divides the words of the three fingers
for us
[Music]
the flame of chaos has nestled within
you
could you please rest your hand upon me
burn me with the flame
to make me your maiden
oh
it burns
my
eyes my eyes
they're melting
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
i have touched them
the words of the three fingers
as your maiden
allow me to define them
all that there is came from the one
great
then came fractures and births
and souls
but the greater will made a mistake
torment
despair
affliction every sin
every curse
every one born of the mistake
and so
what was borrowed
must be returned
melt it all away with the yellow chaos
flame
until all is won again
those who gave me grace
however words
saying they wish they were never born
they come their lord
take their torment
despair their affliction
every sin
every curse
and melt it all away
this lord of chaos
no more fractures
no more birth
the greater will borrowed power from
something known as the one great
using that power it sent the elden beast
down from the stars and created the
elden ring
and with that fractures births and souls
but it made a mistake
which we don't know what that mistake is
it could be a number of things to be
honest
like maybe choosing america as the
vessel for the elden ring
the shattering of the elden ring or
maybe even something far before the time
of the earth tree it's pretty open to
speculation
but born from this mistake was torment
despair affliction sin and curses
because of this the three fingers was
either sent down or came down by itself
to basically erase everything the
greater will had done
so that either it can start over or
abandon its creation entirely
but basically the three-finger's purpose
is to burn everything away so that it is
all returned to the one great
the one who told us this is hayeta who
is a blind girl who seeks to fulfill her
duty as a finger maiden she had seen the
distant light of the frenzied flame
and the more shabriri grapes that she
ate the closer she got to the three
fingers
the distant light that she saw would
lead her to nomads under the influence
of the frenzied flame who would donate
their shabri grapes to her
and eventually it would lead her to the
tarnished who is destined to be lord
we would give her the final grapes that
she needs we also reveal to her the
truth of what she has been eating
human eyes
and though in the start it sickened her
the madness that was growing within her
would supersede her disgust
and she would come to liken the taste of
the eyes
but who would lead her to this path
was the distant light truly assigned for
her to follow
or perhaps it was a manipulation by one
most revile
it is very likely that the three fingers
came to the lens between alongside the
two fingers
but it might not have had a physical
form
thus it could not spread the frenzied
flame at least not until it found perch
within the first apostle and the
incarnation of chaos itself
shabriri
the most reviled man in all history
though we don't know much about him we
know he is a manipulative being
this is evident in our first meeting
with him
[Music]
the
finally
who would be lord
oh my
why the wrong face
i fear that you were previously
acquainted with this vessel
well
that is most unfortunate
for he is dead
as for his flesh
he gave it to me
shabriri
i hope you can make your peace with that
you are about to sacrifice something
precious
the life of a fair maiden
that you would toss into the fiery forge
only so that you may be lord what a
horrible thing to ponder
your ascendancy
requires her sacrifice
whether she wishes it or not
but how would the lord
crown soul
chosen tarnished and would be lord
dare to tread the path of true rigor
spare
the poor girl
and singe your own flesh in her stead
if you are prepared to shall resolve
and attain lordship through righteous
hardship
then heed the words of i
chabri
chosen tarnished and would be lord
descend into the depths far below the
earth tree capital
seek audience with the three fingers and
the flame of frenzy
if you inherit the flame of frenzy
your flesh
will serve as kindling
and the girl
can be spared setting you on the
righteous path of lordship
the path of the lord of chaos
burn the earth tree
to the ground
and incinerate
all that divides and distinguishes
oh may chaos take
the world
may chaos
take
the world
[Music]
his words are filled with lies and
manipulations showing concern for our
relationship with yura
telling us that yura willingly gave his
body which is likely a lie
trying to convince us that melano's
sacrifice is a vile act that melania
herself has no choice in the matter
again another lie
and telling us how this greed and action
would make us look like a terrible lord
lastly conveniently providing us a
solution by meeting the three fingers
though his intent is very clear by the
end of it
because he doesn't really hide his ties
to chaos
this is only one of the manipulations
shabriri would do
that we actually witness
he has done far worse in the history of
the lands between
the wandering merchants that we purchase
items from are all haunted by the
frenzied flame
and it is my belief that it is also
shabriri who put this curse upon them
the shabiri's woe item description tells
us that it is said that the man named
shabriri had his eyes gouged out as
punishment for the crime of slander
and with time the blight of the flame of
frenzy came to dwell in the empty
sockets slander is a crime of making a
false spoken statement damaging to a
person or group's reputation
which group did he slander
the great caravan of the nomadic
merchants the nomadic set tells us that
these merchants once thrived as the
great caravan
but after being accused of heretical
beliefs their clan was rounded up and
buried alive far underground then they
chanted the curse of despair
and summoned the flame of frenzy
it was chabris manipulations that the
merchants have been cursed by the
frenzied flame and it is by this act of
sacrifice by the great caravan that the
three fingers came to be able to
manifest themselves deep within the
underground
shabiri however could not become a lord
for reasons unknown perhaps it's because
he had shed his humanity or maybe
because he was not tarnished or didn't
have the grace to become a lord
as such instead
he would find one to become lord the
lord of chaos
before us
there were those who came close to
becoming an elden lord
but no other tarnished was closer to the
throne of the elden lord
than vike
but without announcement vike traveled
far below the capital and was scorched
by the flame of frenzy
did he make his choice for his maiden or
did some other force lure him with a
suggestion
i think it's pretty safe to assume that
vike probably met shabriri and lured him
to become a lord of chaos like he did
with us
unfortunately for vike he could not
handle the frenzied flame either
this maiden that we see at the church is
probably his maiden
and believers who wish to see him as the
lord of chaos were disappointed when he
failed
the village is also scorched by the
frenzied flame a tower where the flame
itself manifests through a ritual
sits at the entrance of the village
if you kill the enemies on top you can
stop the flame from appearing
it is also here that you come across the
chabris woe talisman
guarded by some carrion soldiers
afflicted with the flame
shabriri's woe attracts the aggression
of enemies and the karyan soldiers may
have been lured here by the carrier of
the talisman
it is also here that we find a note that
gives us a clue where to find the three
fingers
shabri had cast his humanity away long
ago and has become something more
even if you kill him at the mountaintop
of giants
should you pursue the frenzied flame
he will return to assist you in the
fight against godfrey to further your
goal as the lord of
chaos now that you know the machinations
of shabriri we can look at the damage it
has done to the lands between
in limgrave there is a village known as
the ailing village
filled with nomads who are now corrupted
by the frenzied flame
in the frenzied flame village more
nomads appear also corrupted
the nomadic merchants are forever forced
to be nomads
as it seems that settling down in a
village or anywhere
causes the frenzied flame to catch up to
them
scorching their eyes and eroding their
senses
within the blasphemous volcano mount
gelmir the frenzied flame has also
perched upon the trolls and the soldiers
of lingdel corrupting them as they get
closer to the manor
reichard has invited all forms of
blasphemy within his realm and the
frenzied flame is but one of these
in the consecrated snow field some ruins
have been corrupted by the flames
perhaps even the three fingers is wary
of the young mikala and his creation
that wards off the influence of outer
gods
and lastly at the bottom of lane del
where the three fingers dwell within
the corpses of the great caravan still
sit upon the area
haunting the depths with music
to make our way down here is proof of
our capability to become lord
but to accept the frenzied flame is a
trial on its own
melanoma would beg us not to seek the
three fingers for their rule would spell
the doom of the world much worse than
even destined death
should you ignore her plea
the frenzied flame can be yours to
inherit
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
strangely enough even if you are the
lord of chaos the frenzied flame still
burns you perhaps none can truly control
the madness within the flames
in order to save melina we embrace the
frenzied flame
we use our self as the kindling for the
giant's flame
as we burn the earth tree
if you killed millicent and were unable
to create nicholas needle
then we can no longer get away from the
influence of the frenzied flame and the
fate of the lands between is sealed
the only factor now is if melina is
alive or not
if melania is alive then she may yet be
able to stop us from destroying the
world
shabriri helps us take down godfrey and
ratagan is but a stepping stone for a
true lord of chaos
it is here that we must burn the world
end the divide and return everything to
the one
great we the chosen tarnished champion
of the three fingers ascend and because
you